[Music]
a few months ago we started a
nanodegree program on self-driving cars
we are the only institution in the world
who teaches self-driving cars i have
been
blown away what you guys are
accomplishing
building the original self-driving car
program at udacity was kind of crazy
we were given this this really small
team and tasked with building
this instructional program that was more
advanced and more cutting edge than
anything really anybody had done
anywhere
and when we actually opened the program
up for people to enroll
we got thousands and thousands of people
to enroll before the program even
launched many
more than had uh ever enrolled in the
udacity program ahead of time
in the past and it's really it makes me
really proud
the self-driving car industry has
changed so much in the last four years
we realized that enough has changed that
it was time
to to rebuild some portions of the
nanodegree program
the new program has a lot of new
material particularly around perception
and sensor fusion and prediction
and it has new projects using newer more
advanced simulators and one of the
really exciting things that's happened
in the last six months
is our partnership with waymo students
are working with real waymo data
to build projects that they can then go
show to employers and other people in
the industry
we have such a great team building the
self-driving car program right now we
have that luxury that we we might not
have had four years ago of really
picking some of the best experts
from industry to help teach our
our courses
the reason i want to teach a udacity
course is
i really like sharing this knowledge
with other people
even through universities it's difficult
to be able to get all the classes
required
to go into self-driving
it's able to give them the expertise
in that specific field to work in it
later
and dive more into it
you know i dreamt about it is is like
there's nothing
more uh appealing to me than than
teaching something like this that it
could actually
help people to achieve their dreams
especially when it comes to
state-of-the-art technology which is
what this
nanodegree program is about self-driving
cars they will profoundly
change the definition of mobility as we
know it autonomous vehicles will reduce
accidents they will reduce road
fatalities they will make
mobility accessible to everyone
including the elderly or impaired
and they also will reduce traffic
especially in large cities
i think the biggest challenge ahead is
moving from advanced driver assistance
systems to real self-driving cars
where the driver is no fallback option
for human drivers
this task is simple but remember that we
have millions of years of evolution
behind us
so it will take some time for machines
to close this gap
when you look at the number of you know
traffic accident and
deaths linked to traffic accidents um
you know i believe that
last year it was over like 39 000 people
died from from traffic accidents but in
a world that
you know where everyone has a safe
driving car or like everyone is taking a
side driving car to go to work or our
commute
um you know that number should get much
closer to zero right
self-driving cars are going to change
our lives in ways i don't think we can
even imagine
i think all of those things are are just
so exciting
and and offer an opportunity to change
the world and make a real step forward
into a different kind of life
than than we have right now and that
humanity has had before
i think it's just exciting to imagine
that future
[Music]
you